what happened to me does not go away it
stays with you all your life
jim was abused as a child for years by
priests
at his school ignored when he spoke up
just one example out of hundreds
swept into the carpet by the catholic
church i never
ever want to see a child put into any
vulnerable position that i was put into
as an 11 12 13 14 year old three and a
half years i went through it
the vulnerability that i went through i
would absolutely cry if i thought any
child was in that vulnerability
because it was awful the independent
inquiry into child sexual abuse
has found the church in england and
wales put its reputation
first above the welfare of children with
particular
criticism for its leadership the
archbishop of westminster
cardinal vincent nichols i am sorry i am
really
really mortified that this happened
in the context of the catholic church
and over this period of 50 years
and i want to promise you that we will
again
do every single thing in our power to
get our response
right the report highlighted that change
within the church had been
too slow with repeated failures over
decades
if you look at all of our reports all of
them contain very very recent examples
of abuse still happening so it's clearly
still happening
you need people that have the right
experience in supporting
victims when they do come forward so
that that their own experiences
dreadful experience could be used to
prevent it in the future
over 45 years more than 3 000 complaints
of abuse have been received by the
catholic church
against more than 900 individuals the
church
still receives on average more than 100
allegations per year
but the true scale of child sexual abuse
overall
is believed to be far higher the reports
led to calls for the archbishop of
westminster to resign
but survivors like jim just want to see
children protected
today is the day in which i wish to
speak to them first of all
and to say i am very sorry
well yes i expected he would have said
that he's sorry and that that's fine i
accept that
it's not enough though and you know what
it's not enough
that he says he'll do what he says he'll
do he has to be actually
forced to do that from outside i don't
trust the church to do what they should
do
he doesn't want retribution just
reparation for victims and a church
that no longer turns a blind eye adele
robinson sky news